hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to rocket League okay
you're ready for the next match oh I'm
ready are you do you want to like change
any of the possible things of what we
could give me do another like uh I want
to play on different teams I think the
only way to do that is to play against
one finger to v3 I don't want you to be
on the unfair team I don't you know
Devon Helen no holy crap do before oh my
god we have to do that we do it me
versus the other girl oh no oh man this
is gonna be so we didn't even change a
large [ __ ] alright here we go
no okay Oh laser just because they're
smarter doesn't mean they're better than
us oh no no no she okay Oh
if we make baby no there's no way to
think of oh we gonna be shorter anywhere
we've ever done Oh is there like a
certain score that just like makes us
quit they're like no you can't go any
night I have no idea I'm mercy we'll
find out ha ha ha all right I'm gonna
hang back
oh no you go for you go we go thank you
I guess I can't okay not here anymore
I'm coming back I did it I did a thing
bag there's just so many of them we
haven't take some of you here - I didn't
you were okay no you're so no good so
many oh my god I just go in reversion oh
yes yes yes okay good
I'm getting good oh my god uh wait we
can score we can score we can John we
got I got
you're gonna turn good okay oh no no oh
god this is such a bad no no it's a good
idea okay it'll make us better as
players yeah get to the evidence make it
so well get our self-confidence to the
point where we will be undefeatable
undefeated won't be in such shame at
what we've done okay
uh-huh let's I'm gonna take them out
that's all I do I'm gonna try to take
that up all right dude I miss old I
missed the ball was I supposed to do
wait was it was it not gonna go in if I
didn't hit it I know I know yes you're
closer I wanna kill him oh my gosh um
okay yeah I missed a mouse oh hi Rory
I'm sorry oh we're so bad all right we
can do this we just have to pull
together all right are you here we go
I'm going okay give me that well I ran
out of boost that later I don't know
what happened oh don't let him please
don't let him school I'm on the way I'm
on the way no here we go okay it's mine
huh no no I got it yes yes
all right he was a common he was going
on right yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yeah yeah
despite my best effort to blow my own
goal oh man right there at bluff oh yeah
good you're good to go we prison good he
just obliterated into not exist all
right go for it go for it you got it you
got it you got it
you got you got you got you got her got
it gotta go no don't go no [ __ ] we're
both over what happened yeah oh you took
on the blue I'm so bad is the longest
five minutes of gaming history God we're
gonna have a mercy Roy if they get to
ten I'm just gonna cut it there what if
we're done we pretend I know what you
know oh you're closer you definitely
click okay I'm gonna hurt her
okay I gotta chit chit chit drink no I'm
on the ceiling okay so calm
I just want status up no thanks it's
okay okay
oh dear look if you guys know they're
always there you did it together though
we did it together okay okay yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah boosts
okay wait wait oh no it's lemony flew
damn it I'm gonna screw you oh no no no
no a little bit the Shepherd I have no
boost I've no good okay wha
oh you made that afternoon yeah you made
this she watch how bad you did this I
thought that I was coming for it oh I
thought I did
whatever shut up we just need to get one
other score and then I can consider this
a win are you going for it I'm going for
it okay let's go for it
oh well there we go ow okay okay yeah so
what god is depending up we're gonna
call it when we may close to that goal
okay you're gonna drive it over a
background I'm gonna drive it over oh I
miss it Oh Oh God
I can't hit this ball for the life when
I can't judge it how the distance is
gonna be that you're so good at hitting
it the wrong way
I know my intercept courses are just all
off skip damn it I don't want to see
this embarrassment let's skip it
hey you're closer you know Google I'm
going I'm going
what you think I'm doing of course I'm
going hey oh thank you if I was the ball
this would be great but I'm not oh [ __ ]
what you doing over me squall don't
why'd you give up I was in Quebec catch
and you could have boosted what that
guy's like jumped that guy disappeared
from one moment to another you cheated
you cheated these guys are cheating
cheaters maybe that's why it's called
unfair yeah okay we had your closer I
know we can do this I'm gonna hang back
and all of them scored Hey
Oh came back so far that they're gonna
score I did a front flip yeah you like
it
see my friend flip your Hey okay it's
good what a girl oughta come in I
counted the ball was up and we're all
like cuz our cameras are focused on the
ball really close eyes pretty
oh yeah there's people who straight up
and then just boom we're
kill someone oh well well their monthly
annotation no they're not but you just
got a blow you good going well okay that
I'm good
suck it boomer get out of here Boomhauer
I got it I got like I got no go get it
go guys
Harris okay I'm so hard oh I missed
okay well make the strangest no okay
okay 100% moves
there was nothing letting me look at my
desperateness let's keep going let's
keep going I believe in us oh there's
leaving us fixed you oh I'm sliding
upside down CIL's schnitzel Zeus
schnitzels its missiles my cousin from
no no you were right there
no just skip the replays we got it guys
all right I keep forgetting we can't
come back you forget our three plays oh
no no no no ha oh [ __ ] is not is
boggling
tits oh can we have a minute to score 11
times we twelve times if we want well if
you want to win it'll go to sudden death
we know what your win that what if we
just cover the goal like okay northern
well go to the
bill to go bill to go cover the go cover
the dryer we got I like covered to good
I got you got that so I got I got hey
y'all got oh I was no yeah all rights go
to an article covering the goal okay I'm
going in on the offensive you Val Venis
Vita yes No
oh if I was over there I probably could
have helped yeah that would have been a
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah where are
you Barry you can be only return cv
Goswami the [ __ ] one thing the only
objective is to not let them scourge
don't do that our school school I don't
care about our score oh I can't wait to
play against you all right oh okay I
know there's five people in the comms
like wow I could beat you before I'm
like try it yeah oh no I tell you you
and why am I always that still
I got I got I'm over here oh there we go
on the wall turn it around no I'm not
never mind they're wrong ah [ __ ]
oh sure no way yeah I got a skull I was
good to see I'm gonna win Hey look
lightning well you'll never see this
about you'll never see this episode this
is on the the deleted scene yeah too hot
for YouTube 10 million dollars a disc
for this episode who their worst player
scored more than I did
I had an assist on that one though
whatever with that three say it's
building at three gunshot all right so
thank you already so much for watching
the next episode we're gonna fight each
other cuz this is cheats worst teammate
ever I can't wait to be don't have
paints I just look stupid
yeah that's how you're crying they're
like you're gonna be way to be away from
my good friend mark
hmm thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
bicycle kick we would already play that
[ __ ] yes we're gonna win